foreign
[Music]
regardless of whether it's a space
adventure a dystopian vision of the
future or the good old post-apocalypse
science fiction movies have become
scarce and exciting projects are often
limited to streaming or made into series
however there are still some movies that
make it to the big screen in this video
you can learn what you can look forward
to in the coming months in terms of
science fiction enjoy
the first big hit is already coming at
the end of September Gareth Edwards the
director of Godzilla and Rogue one
introduces us to the Creator this time
in a dystopian future marked by a
devastating nuclear strike on Los
Angeles a decade ago a fierce conflict
unfolds between Mankind and AI robots
that were once created to protect the
human race the scars of War are still
fresh for Joshua a former Special Forces
agent who is still mourning the loss of
his beloved wife but suddenly he is
called On A Dangerous Mission he is
tasked with tracking down and
eliminating the mysterious Creator the
Obscure architect of advanced artificial
intelligence the Fearsome Weapon made by
this Creator could forever determine the
struggle for Supremacy between the
opposing factions but in the middle of
the ai's territory Joshua encounters
Alfie instead the question arises can it
really be that this AI child holds the
fate of the entire human species in its
hands or is there a possibility that it
could rise up against its own Creator
the Creator will be out in theaters on
September 29th and the trailer so far
are already treating us to a true
spectacle
okay the following title is not the most
pure science fiction movie but hey
aliens space stations cool technology
the new MCU movie the Marvels is
certainly worth checking out and that's
what it's all about Carol Danvers AKA
Captain Marvel has successfully
reclaimed her identity from the
tyrannical cree and taken revenge on the
Supreme intelligence but this heroic act
has unexpected consequences she now
Bears the burden of responsibility for
an unstable Universe fate leads Carol to
a mysterious Wormhole that is a link to
a Cree revolutionary here something
incredible happens her powers suddenly
merge with those of Kamala Khan AKA Ms
Marvel as well as Carol's niece Monica
Rambo AKA saber every time one of the
three uses her powers they switch places
with another together they must form an
unbeatable team and learn to work hand
in hand working as the Marvels is the
only way they can Master the challenges
of the universe and save it from
impending doom the film can be seen
starting November 10th 2023.
[Music]
it's been eight years since the final
movie about The Hunger Games that
Katniss Everdeen The Hunger Games
Mockingjay Part 2 hit theaters those who
feared that this would be the end of the
stories from panum have reason to
Rejoice a fifth installment of the
series will hit theaters in November the
Hunger Games The Ballad of songbirds and
snakes is a prequel that is likewise
based on a book in the film The Hunger
Games will be the focus once again of
course 63 years before Katniss Everdeen
PanAm is still shaken by the Civil War
which occurred 10 years ago for 16 year
old Lucy gray as tribute of District 12.
it's a matter of bear survival but her
love affair with her Mentor Corey Elena
snow seems to give her the one or other
Advantage during the competition snow on
the other hand has his own Ambitions he
is working to restore his family honor
after it fell out of favor during the
uprisings as a mentor during The Hunger
Games he soon discovers his talents
which will later help him become
president we're also looking forward to
the story of casca high bottom the
involuntary inventor of The Hunger Games
the first trailer already wedded the
appetite for more and may have already
convinced Die Hard fan chance to go to
the movies again the
thing from November 17 2023
the Blockbuster sequel Dune 2 was
recently postponed to Spring 2024. of
course that's no reason to look forward
to the science fiction epic any less
after part one the initial situation is
clear Darkness has come to the Broken
House of tradies Baron harkona now holds
the reins of power once again on the
Relentless planet of Iraqis backed by
the emperor's favor Paul and his mother
Jessica are the sole survivors of House
of Trades they owe their survival to
their daring escape attempt into the
merciless desert there they have joined
the native Freeman whose lives are
defined by the heat the sand and giant
sand worms creatures that make the
extraction of the precious spice
substance a dangerous challenge so Paul
hides out in the middle of the desert
supported by the Freeman stillgar and
Chaney in Hindi he forms a desperate
resistance against the oppressors but at
the same time he can no longer flee from
his Destiny as a muadib a role
attributed to him in his Visions these
Visions point to an imminent holy war
that threatens to take over the entire
universe on his behalf epic battles and
revenge against the harkonen seem
unavoidable the new release 8 is March
15 2024.
in 2015 the post-apocalyptic action film
Mad Max Fury Road took over the movie
scene and left a lasting impression on
fans and critics this was not only
appreciated at the box office in 2016.
the movie won a total of six Academy
Awards next year the time will finally
come for the prequel Mad Max furiosa to
hit theaters at the beginning of the
story furiosa still lives in the green
place of many mothers but she won't stay
there for long as she states at the end
of the last film she was gone for 7 000
days this corresponds approximately to
the mentioned 20 years difference to
Fury Road furiosa is kidnapped from her
home and falls into the hands of a biker
gang led by the warlord dementas since
the movie is supposed to cover a longer
period of time we will probably see some
of her time in this harsh environment
and how these challenges change her as a
person in their raids demantis and his
group eventually encounter immortan Joe
and the Citadel a war between the two
parties ensues in the midst of this
battle for Supremacy furiosa must
overcome many trials to find her way
home according to the official plot of
course those familiar with previous
movie know that she will ultimately stay
in the Citadel the question remains
however whether she will join a Morton
Joe of her own free will or whether you
will keep her as some kind of War trophy
the movie has its premiere on May 24
2024 which is already an absolute
must-see for us
six years have already passed since the
last film in the Alien series alien
Covenant so it's about time for a reboot
of the iconic monster from outer space
especially considering the success of
its counterpart the predator in the
Disney plus film prey last year however
we still have to remain patient for a
bit the new film with the working title
alien Romulus is not due to be released
until the second half of next year the
film will tell a separate story that is
entirely unrelated to the previous
entries in the alien Saga this means
that there will be no direct ties to the
events in Prometheus Covenant or the
original Alien films the creators of the
film emphasize that they chose this
approach to make it easier for newcomers
to the alien Universe in addition to
Loyal fans the plot of alien Romulus
will focus on a group of young people
who come into contact with the dreaded
facehuggers on a secluded Outpost these
creatures lay their eggs in human hosts
to give birth to the dangerous
Xenomorphs however it remains unclear
whether the story takes place solely on
the planet or whether it explores other
locations as well likewise the question
of possible sequels or a t TV series in
the alien Universe remains open it is
known that Noah Hawley the producer of
Fargo is working on an Alien series
whether it will tie into this story
however has not yet been revealed alien
Romulus will hit theaters on August 16
2024 and is of course an absolute
must-see for all sci-fi fans
when it comes to action and science
fiction there's no getting around one
particular franchise Transformers after
there have already been several
approaches at making movies the creators
of Optimus Bumblebee and the like are
trying something new with Transformers
1. this time the action is supposed to
take place mainly on Cybertron and
before the big civil war between
Autobots and Decepticons the animated
film will focus on Optimus and Megatron
at a young age who are not foes at the
time but brothers in arms and Friends
their friendship and relationship with
each other and how it paved the way to
the great civil war is sure to be an
exciting cinematic experience for all
fans due to the fact that the movie is
set on their home planet spectacular
footage is bound to happen the premiere
is set for September 13 2024.
those were some of the science fiction
movies we are most excited about which
what are you looking forward to the most
and do you know a sci-fi classic that
urgently needs a sequel or a remake let
us know in the comments and if there are
enough likes from you we'll be happy to
make a second video after all there can
never be enough talk about science
fiction
[Music]